- Welcome back to Baba Knows
Best, the only game show
where real brown dads
compete for cold hard cash.
We're down to our final
three dads. Let's meet them.
Up first an aerospace engineer
from Seattle, Washington,
give it up for Mohammad.
Now, Mohammad
I hear one of your hobbies
is reading the newspaper?
- I love newspaper.
- Okay. Our next baba,
is from Fremont, California,
he's a mechanical engineer.
Ladies and gentlemen,
give it up for Akbar.
Akbar, I hear you were recently
kicked out of a Costco
for trying too many samples?
- I go in, and they said, "No
sir, you can not keep eating
the tortilla chip with salsa."
I said, "Goddamn it, I pay.
I will eat as much salsa
and chip as I need to do."
- Our last baba is from
Baltimore, Maryland.
He's a structural engineer.
Ladies and gentlemen,
it's Nassar.
Nassar, I hear that you like to
mow your lawn in your Speedos?
- What do you mean?
On the form, you said one of
the activities you like to do-
- Right.
... is mowing the lawn-
- I mow lawn.
... over the weekend
in your Speedo?
- Yes, I'm in Speedo.
What am I going to do?
Wear my underwear?
- Alright.
Let's play our next game,
What's the Matter with Shoe.
Alright, you guys
know the rules.
Every justified direct hit
on a target is five points.
Hit the wrong target,
you lose five points.
Your money shoe
is worth triple points.
You guys ready?
Yes.
Yeah.
Let's go.
- Dad, I got a C.
- Whoa, five points
across the board.
- I got into UCLA.
- Double points for Akbar.
- Ivy League only!
- I'm gonna kill this, bitch.
- I'm gonna burn this
fucking house house down.
- I had some bacon.
- Whoa. Now, Akbar,
you hit the arsonist,
but your son
did have bacon,
so he's gonna burn
in hell forever.
- My hands are sweaty.
- Minus five points.
- We're forming a band.
- Ah! Come here, son.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Shoes down. Time's up.
Now, Nassar, you did hit the kid
with the frosted tips,
but you used your own shoe,
so no points there.
- Shit!
- That was a great round.
Let's check in on our podiums
to see who's in the lead.
Alright, Mohammed
is in the lead,
but it's still anyone's game.
Let's move on
to our final challenge,
Like a Rock.
We'll play out real life
events from your life.
Whoever doesn't cry wins
the challenge and the game.
You guys ready? Let's play.
- Push! Come on. One more. Push.
It's your son.
- I'm all packed up.
Thank for everything you
and mom have done for me.
I'm gonna miss you, dad.
- Baba, you made the perfect
home for me growing up.
I can only hope to create
the same for my family.
One last dance?
- Wow. Hearts of stone.
It's almost as
if you aren't human,
but how will you react
to this message
from your real life fathers?
- Son, I love you.
- Baba.
- Wow. It's a photo finish.
We're gonna have
to go to replay.
Let's take a look.
Mohammed cried last, so it looks
like Mohammed is the winner.
- When did Baba say this?
- He didn't.
Thank you to our CGI team
who mocked up the perfect
photo of your fathers,
because, of course,
they would never say that.
Billy, why don't you tell us
what Mohammed has won?
- You'll be going home
in our grand prize,
a 2006 Toyota Camry.
Kelly Blue Book value is $6296,
but we got it for $5.
- That's a good deal.
- It always is on
Baba Knows Best!